after 1.1 million hours of construction  the fusion reactor Bendel shrine 7x is  ready to switch on over 16 meters across  Bendel's x 7x is the largest example of  a type of reactor known as a stellar  Raider like the more familiar tokamak  reactors stellarators holds superhot gas  in a cage of powerful magnetic fields  Bendel stein 7x has been optimized by a  supercomputer to produce the best  possible magnetic cage 50 bizarrely  twisted superconducting magnets look  more like sculptures than pieces of  precision engineering they are cooled to  minus 270 degrees Celsius and operate  just a meter away from the gaps at 100  million degrees if fan - 9 7 X can show  it holds on to gas as well as a tokamak  and stellarators may step into the  limelight building this complex machine  has taken 19 years but researchers hope  when they turn it on that it will  recreate a little bit of the Sun  you